joining me now is blake masters
candidate for the u.s senate in arizona
blake chuck coughlin an arizona-based
gop strategist told politico today that
based on numbers that we have
republicans have to make some kind of
leap on the abortion issue because
they're getting killed among women
your response
you know laura what i think we're seeing
is propaganda this is the media's
desired narrative they are trying to
make this election all about abortion
the democrats mark kelly in arizona he
wants to just talk about abortion
because they don't want to talk about
the wide open southern border they don't
want to talk about double digit
inflation they don't want to talk about
how our kids are being taught
transgender ideology in our schools you
know they don't want to talk about their
failures so they're trying to jit up
outrage on the abortion issue and i just
don't believe that that is going to be
the issue uh that voters have stopped
you on abortion at all i mean there's a
reference to you on the website that you
might have tweeted or more propaganda
i've been consistent throughout the
whole primary i've always said hey
what's your position i think we should
have gotten rid of roe v wade thank god
the supreme court did that with dobbs
that sends the issue back to the states
where it mostly belongs now i happen to
believe the federal government does have
a role i think it should step in and ban
extremely late term abortions right but
the pro-life uh we in the pro-life
movement we take the fight to the states
and i think that's where you believe in
exceptions for the life of the mother
absolutely and mark kelly lies about
that but they have to lie because they
have nothing good to run on themselves
you and i were talking uh during the
break about mark kelly where is mark
kelly i never see him
ever i mean it's not that you have to
live and breathe on television but
it's like he doesn't exist he hides away
he does the joe biden 2020 hide in the
basement a hologram candidate he's a
hologram
you know he's got all this money and he
runs these fake ads where he pretends to
be a moderate republican but you know
actually no people know he's just voting
in dc in lockstep 95
94 97
basically when it matters most chuck
schumer owns mark kelly's vote now um
one month from today you're going to
have one debate is that it that's right
he agreed to one debate we challenged
him to four in hopes that he would just
agree to one and we got him so he's
going to debate me and i think it's
going to be especially moderating it do
you know the pbs you know they'll be
somewhat left left-leaning but you know
what that's okay i'll play an away game
no no no it'll be fair now i like this
line from ronna mcdaniel who wrote a
piece um that i missed came out just a
few days ago in the hill
about how he's kind of like fetterman in
a way not that he has a health issue
thank goodness but
that he pretends to be this everyman
moderate but he's really just a
california liberal who happens to you
know be running uh for re-election in
arizona but he's not really a he's not
really a moderate on any issue he's not
he's voting hyper he basically acts like
bernie sanders in the united states
senate but then he has the audacity to
pretend to be moderate i think mark
kelly's doing a you know fantastic job
as california's third senator what he's
failing at is representing the people of
arizona that's why we need to make a
change in november yeah the the
narrative is going to be to demoralize
arizonans before this vote i'm telling
everybody don't believe anything the
media is saying this is going to be a
hot race to watch blake i really
appreciate you coming good to see you in
the studio thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else